LuAnn de Lesseps and Tom D'Agostino call
it quits I felt like somebody just
ripped apart my world The Real
Housewives of New York City star took to
Twitter on Thursday to announce that she
and Tom are ending their marriage after
just seven months quote it's with great
sadness that Tom and I agreed to divorce
we care for each other very much hope
you respect our privacy during this sad
time the news comes just two weeks after
the couple made headlines over an
alleged argument at a restaurant where
LuAnn reportedly slapped Tom a claim she
denied on watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen I did not slap him we have a
very passionate love affair going okay
and let me tell you we never go to bed
angry but when we do when we wake up we
make up the two got engaged in February
2016 and tied the knot last New Year's
Eve of course that was after tom was
caught kissing another woman she was
giving you a kiss you were making out
for an hour
LuAnn opened up to et in 2016 about her
then fiance's infidelity we love each
other and you know I always say if you
can't forgive the people you love and
who can you forgive and the fact is that
Tom and I love each other and we're
getting married and I'm not gonna let a
silly kiss ruin the rest of our lives